[Music]
foreign
[Music]
invincibility that you're talking about
too I would imagine you know you know
going in and you know putting your patch
down and saying I'm out and then you
know the difference I I was uh can you
just sort of explain well you know I
have
been building up to it building up to it
I didn't discuss it with anybody nobody
absolute uh
solo uh decision
my son was walking up to the door in the
clubhouse I can remember and I I said I
need to talk to you son and I put my arm
around him and we walked up the street
and uh
I said I'm hanging it up tonight
so we'll see
probably
late 20s and was he was he a member yes
he was a member and I said I'm hanging
it up tonight he goes what and I go look
man
I said I've come to terms of a lot of
things and I said this is not the club I
joined and I said I just I can't do it
anymore and uh I said you know people
aren't sharing my vision I go uh you
know
when you are a leader you share your
vision with the people behind you and
when they no longer share that Vision
you know maybe you're not a leader
anymore and I said it's time for me to
reevaluate where I'm heading in this
journey I'm on and uh
my mind's made up I'm gonna I'm gonna
hang it up so I went in where was he at
with that
he just
kissed me and said you know hugged me
and said okay dad you know best I know
you know what you need to do for
yourself and he walked in there and uh I
uh
now stood up announced to the club uh
what I was doing initially they thought
that I was stepping down as president
and I said no no that's not what this is
I said I'm I'm stepping down and I you
know I took my patch off and I folded it
like a flag
and uh
I looked around the room and I didn't
see anybody I wanted to hand it to you
know I wanted to exclude my son I didn't
think uh you know he should be part of
that decision and I laid it on the
corner of the table and uh I said if
anybody's got anything to say say it now
and nobody said anything it was very sad
very emotional and I'll tell you the
walk
from my chair I always sat in a chair
against the back wall I was the
president's chair
of the walk from that chair to the door
the threshold of the door to let me out
was the longest walk I ever took in my
life we was going through your mind your
heart just thinking man there's no
turning back now George you know you
made this decision you got to live with
it and uh
what does that entail like what is it
what in that in that moment what did you
think living with it entailed
I thought that uh foolishly I thought
that I would be able to go about my
business uh
wasn't sure John
about a week and a half I got a phone
call from the new president of the
charter and he said you know we've been
doing a lot of thinking and we've
decided to change our status you're now
out bad you can have absolutely no
contact uh
with any club members and they can't
contact you in any way and I said
well you know I said it's kind of
interesting I said at least the
government
always gave me the opportunity to answer
to the charges I go you guys aren't even
going to give me the opportunity and he
basically he said that's not the one
that's not the way Sunny wants it and
sunny and I had been at odds and uh I uh
despite that you know I I respected the
man till the end I didn't agree with him
what was the Crux of your disagreement
political decisions uh I guess the
biggest uh disagreement was
Sonny felter were two sets of rules
rules for the entitled uh members and
then you had your general membership can
you be a little bit more specific like
what what are those different rules like
what like he did what he wanted
yeah
I I really John I can't make it any more
clearer than that I mean uh
I'm working on a new book and uh
defining the differences in our
leadership styles uh it's not a uh I'm
not slinging mud at him uh you know I
got a phone call
maybe this can explain a little bit I
got a phone call the night before he
died you know I was not allowed to have
any contact with any club members but I
have had
since I've been gone people write me and
call me and I certainly keep it in
confidence I don't want to get them in
trouble because it was you know a kick
out of the club if you got caught
communicating with me and uh
I think he said
person on the other hand you know he's
basically said you recognize with his
voice and I said yeah and I we kind of
have bantered back and forth I teased
him uh I said yeah it's my Rabbi and uh
you know we just went back and forth and
joking he said I got something to tell
you and I said what's that because if
you're going to reconcile with Ralph
that's what we you know close circle of
friends call him so if you're going to
reconcile with route he better do it
because uh he's not going to last much
longer and I you know I stayed up the
rest of that night and uh drinking
coffee and thinking and uh
I decided against calling him because
and this was kind of a selfish decision
I figured that if I called him and we
got an argument and he passed away uh
during the the discussion I'd get the
blame for killing him yeah yeah yeah so
I'd be a little facetious but there's
also some some truth of what I'm saying
so I you know I uh I decided against it
and I thought uh
you know it's interesting when I when I
did the outlaw Chronicles
the Dead
days and days you know what it's like to
film you know you do it you do it you do
it and then they take the best stuff and
they saved the uh last episode of The
Sixth episode you know sunny and myself
for last and it was
really profound the producer of that
show who I have a lot of respect for
uh when the when the
day was over with
he just looked at me and he goes you
still love that guy don't you you
respect him and uh he goes man he goes
you could have thrashed him and he goes
and I said there was no reason to thrash
him I go what he did was what he did
what I did was what I did were two
different leaders to do different styles
but the guy's an icon you know I mean
Sonny Barger man you know I was hearing
about him in in school you know in high
school and the guys I you know I hung
out with uh hung out with a young Outlaw
bike club called the question marks who
were endorsed by the Hell's Angels I
mean he was a living legend there's no
doubt about it when you're in that room
and you give the guys that that speech
and you decide to leave the patch on the
table
do you love the guys in that room sure
yeah right there but
I dream about those guys John I mean I
had some profound dreams I haven't found
dreams anyways I always have my whole
life but uh
you know I had dreams of the older guys
that were had passed on to the other
side you know
I can't believe you did it man and then
I would have young guys in the dreams
coming to me asking me questions and I
go I I can't give you the answers I'm
not in the club anymore you know I would
wake up and uh you know sometimes I wake
up by one you know a very profound
intense dreams I don't have them like I
did but I you know I still have
I still have those friends
[Music]